Good evening, guys. This is a video about studying
multiple foreign languages and...
how you can switch between those different languages
without getting confused and mixed up
If you looked at my channel before, you've seen that
I've studied a number of different foreign languages.
Maybe you've studied a number of different foreign languages
and maybe you found it kind of confusing or...
maybe you've found there's some overlap between the language
or you've crossed wires between language.
Maybe it gets confusing when you study more than one.
how do you keep them all inside your head
and be able to speak
more than a couple languages like five,
six, seven languages. How do you do it?
Well, keep in mind I'm talking from the point of view
of someone who's studied all these foreign languages
as an adult.
I didn't learn any foreign language or
second language as a kid
I was raised monolingual, speak English. So this
is from that point of view of learning as an adult.
Someone who learned it as a kid might be different.
Just keep that in mind. Ok so basically...
There are three things. I will start with the first one:
I think you really need to refine
your pronunciation for each of the languages.
You really need to get specific ...
with the distinctions you make in the phonology.
So really look at all the different sounds
in each language and get them as...
as specific and as precise as possible.
Because  I think  a lot of what causes crossover
between  different languages is that...
you are using the same phonology
or similar phonology for those languages.
When a native speaker has a very precise
distinct phonology for that language.
So this is something ...[/]   My theory on this
came from studying a few different languages.
I studied Hebrew and Arabic which are quite related
but the phonology isn't that similar, they're quite different.
But also I've studied French and I find that I've had
a lot more crossover between French and Hebrew
than between Arabic and Hebrew, even though
French and Hebrew are not related really.
And that's because there are some similar
phonological sounds between Hebrew and French
don't exist between Hebrew and Arabic.
So that's caused some of the crossover between them.
It's the phonology, it's the similar phonology.
So in order to solve that problem, I had to
really get precise with my phonology
for French and for Hebrew.
I had to look at all the sounds, look at...
exactly how to pronounce those sounds
that were causing the confusion.
So you can do that, I mean... when I say
refine your pronunciation, it's in general...
focus on studying your pronunciation and improving it.
Get some help from native speakers,
really focus on emulating native speakers.
But also at a more advanced level,
I'll teach you a little technique that ...
that helps people take it to a more
native level or near-native level.
The technique is this : imagine that...
a particular native speaker
is actually speaking through you.
It might sound strange but they're your kind of
channeling a certain person through your body
and they're speaking out your mouth.
Like when I speak French, I imagine that Sarkozy,
the former president, is speaking through me.
Because he's somebody that I modeled when I was
studying French, I have paid attention to
his pronunciation, tried to copy his intonation.
So when I speak French,
when I'm trying to get precise with my pronunciation,
I imagine it's him speaking through me.
Right? And when I speak tagalog,
I imagine a certain...
filipino person who I know, who speaks tagalog.
I Imagine that person is speaking through me.
And by doing that, you're really...
Your brain is picking up on a lot of very little subtle cues
in the pronunciation that you can't pick up on consciously.
if you try to focus on all those little differences,
you can't really do it but...
if you just focus on the whole person, your unconscious
mind can pick up on all those little fine-tuned elements
of the pronunciation and it helps you out a lot.
So that's one thing, one trick you can try for getting
your pronunciation to a more authentic level.
Okay so focus on the pronunciation :
that's my first piece of advice.
The second thing is 100% commitment.
No half stepping 100% commitment
when you are switching into the next language.
Okay, so when you are moving from one language
into the other, it's kind of like you are walking through
a doorway into another room.
If you enter the doorway
and you just stand in the doorway,
and try to speak the other language of the other room,
you're going to retreat into the first room,
you're going to go back into the other language.
Or you're going to get some crossover between the 2,
you'll find it hard to really move into the 2nd language.
So what you really need to do is just make a firm decision.
Okay, now, I'm switching into the other language.
I'm not going back into the old one, I'm walking through
the doorway and I'm closing the door behind me.
Right?So, you're...
You're basically just completely deciding:
I'm speaking this language now and not the other.
You don't want to switch back and forth.
So you want to just lock the door behind you.
Okay so... it's really just about pushing yourself
and making a firm commitment. And...
When you make that firm decision to speak this one,
then it motivates you and pushes you forward.
And it takes you into that zone of that language. Ok?
So that's the second thing, just that 100% decision.
Okay I'm going to speak French now,
I'm going to speak arabic now.
And completely cut off the language
you were speaking a moment earlier.
Alright. So that's number two.
Number three is a little more abstract and it's one
that I don't use all that often anymore, but I used it.
I've tried it in the past and made use of it
when I needed it. And it's like this :
You imagine a scene that you associate
with the language that you want to speak.
So, for example, when I speak French,
I might imagine a scene,
on the patio of a café in Paris. Right?
And imagine all of the the subtle little sensory cues
that go along with that, like...
the taste of wine and the smell of my baguette.
And all that kind of stuff and hearing the ambience around
me, hearing the French language spoken around me.
So by doing that, you're...
creating a connection between
the language and that image.
So that, whenever you want to move into that...
that state in which is you are speaking the language well,
then you imagine that image and
it brings you into the zone of that language.
Okay. So that's something you can try.
Another example of it when I speak Hebrew, I imagine...
the time I spent in Jerusalem
because that's a very vivid time for me.
So I can bring myself back to that time, imagine the
environment, imagine a certain situation I was in, in that place.
Where I can hear Hebrew speakers
and I see different cultural things,
that remind me of the Hebrew language and all of that.
So all of those things are associations that bring me
back into the zone when I was speaking Hebrew well.
All of these pieces of advice are kind of abstract.
I wish I could be a bit more...
logical and scientific in the tips I'm giving.
Well, when we're dealing with...
We're dealing with switching from one language
to another, we're dealing with switching in two different states.
And that kind of requires you to take control of your perception.
Right. It's not the same for everybody so if...
these tips don't really work for you
then you don't have to use them of course, just...
but think about similar types of techniques
and how you can control your perception in a way that...
will take you into that zone where you are
speaking the language well.
So a lot of it has to do with associations
and connections with that language.
Another thing I should point out is that...
the languages that you haven't spoken recently
are always going to fade a little bit...
if you leave them in the background right?
The ones that you can move into the most easily
are the ones you have used most recently.
So don't expect to use one of these techniques and ...
be able to speak really well and really really instantly
in a language you haven't spoken in five years.
You might be able to with the basics of that language.
but you won't be at the level you were
at it, five years ago, obviously.
Because you start to lose
some of the language gradually.
So just keep that in mind.
It's also a matter of...
just keeping the language fresh and keeping them...
well practiced. You can't always do that with all of them.
If you speak 10 languages,
you can't speak all 10 everyday.
So you'll always have some that are more...
ready to go than others and the others
are more waiting in the background for you to ...
retrieve them and start to practice and...
and brush up on those languages.
And then, they'll be in the forefront
and ready to get into the zone again.
Alright... so that's all you got to say about that.
I hope that's clear.
'talk to you later...